you know I always um I always have felt
like life was happening at me
or to me and uh the other day somebody
said hey you know life is happening for
you and it really gave me a softer just
put me at ease like somebody just hit a
quilt just under my skin suddenly you
know just like somebody just wrapped
like a million gooses just around my
neck or something it just made me feel
more comfortable hearing that that life
isn't happening to me it's happening for
me because I always had this pressure
that I'm just standing in the wind and I
don't even yeah nobody else can even
feel I can't even feel the wind but me
man I'm like his way and II I'm always
just standing in the wind but there
really is no wind it's just me thinking
that life is happening to me
my life is happening for me man we got
this let's get this happy novembre
novembri no bummer a couple different
ways to say it a few variations for you
let me take you right here on this
little head
[Music]
celebrate
celebrate ms
No
died
fun while we
celebrate dark days celebrate oh yo
and I wish I could dance
[Music]
have some fun while we all die oh yeah
right there and you know I'm not a DJ
cuz I cut the song off real hard like
that I'll cut that song up but you know
a DJ really kind of fades like this is
what a DJ would have done right there a
DJ would have done this just kind of
faded it out that's not even that good
Jesus what's up I could have never been
a DJ do we had a guy when I was young
this dude named John DJ John that was
his name or DJ ice cold or something or
cold boy or something or you know DJ
free-throw freezing or something I don't
know what it was it was just something
it was around the time when ice was like
the cool term like Ice Cube was a rapper
ice-t basically people a lot of rappers
were named out of things out of the
frigerator kind of and they had a guy
named John in our town and he was the
only dude that had he got like the first
CD changer and he would do all of the he
did funerals he did weddings he did
school dances everything this guy was
the music man and he had an old it was
like um he had a horse trailer you know
a lot of time you see a horse trailer on
the interstate when somebody's moving a
horse somewhere stealing a horse a lot
of times that's stealing he and you kids
always wave at the horse like it's not
being stolen or something but and he uh
and he had a horse trailer and he would
put his stuff in the back of it and he
would show up dude and he had some
speakers I mean one of the speaker's had
it was probably about 15 feet tall bro I
mean that thing
if you just set something on top of it
nobody could ever see it and that's
really how much height was on that sound
piece and and and he was the man DJ ice
I think it was ice boy or something I
don't know he had the shittiest name but
but in a small town what first person to
get a speaker is suddenly the DJ first
person to get that the six disc shuffler
suddenly he got a business and that you
know a lot of times it's just the first
person to get there really is the one
and get it started you know you really
become that he was really the
Christopher Columbus of sound in our
town when he'd show up things that were
real normal before suddenly he'd show up
you know you'd be at a funeral and
suddenly you'd hear some [ __ ] pour
some sugar on me
or you'd hear in Farmer I love that man
dude this was the time of year they had
a dance when I was growing up called
Sadie Hawkins and I don't know who Sadie
Hawkins I think was someone who had I
guess it was someone who had a twin or
something in the twin died or went
missing or was hiding and the dance was
the woman at school had to ask the man
the girls at school had to ask the boy
and the girls had to ask the boy in and
then you had to get a shirt for the
person and wear the same shirt and it
was called Sadie Hawkins and and you
were twins at that point you were twins
and that's how it kind of tied back into
the you know missing person or whatever
but um but dude I remember Sadie Hawkins
in the first day you go to school and
like it was like usually about three
weeks before people would start asking
people and you'd start singing a girl
across the way and be like aw she might
ask me and then you would hear that
she's going with somebody you're like
[ __ ] okay you know
you know Alison isn't asking me so maybe
Katie maybe Katie you asked me you know
and you would wait and then you would
hear all Katie's going with Ricki like
all [ __ ] I thought they were siblings
but whatever and then you'd wait a
little longer you liked all yeah maybe
Tiffani you know maybe thick Tiffani
with them [ __ ] big you know with them
big knees bro
we had a girl named Tiffany had the
biggest [ __ ] knees you ever seen her
just like somebody hit a basketball and
each one of her damn legs right in the
middle and dude I remember thinking she
was gonna ask me one time and and she
didn't ask me and then I'm like Jesus
Christ dude I'm have to go if I'm left
to dance it one of the chaperones and so
it just got you know [ __ ] got real
minimal and then and then just a friend
asked me that's who I'll always in I was
always the guy that ended up going to
the dance with a friend you know some
girl I you know all like I had a buddy
and he was real handsome and so he got
all of you know when when you were a kid
it wasn't really people weren't really
touching each other's crotches or you
know doing anything there wasn't really
like a lot of sex but it was just
sweating you just get around someone you
really liked him you just [ __ ] just
sweat by him that's how you know because
you were so nervous you know you would
just get around I remember this girl
kitty man and I'd get around her and I
was just [ __ ] I couldn't even talk I
just [ __ ] loved her so much
and I just wanted to damn I wanted to
marry her so bad bro even though I was
just like [ __ ] 11 or something or 10
not even 11 man and I just wanted to
marry her so bad and a [ __ ] all I
would do is just stand by her and just
[ __ ] sweat and just look like a freak
bro but that's how you express love at
that age you know what to sit there like
a
damn waterfall you know I'd sit there
like a just like the back of a [ __ ]
dying whale bro just still pretty damp
you know just glistening yes oh just
nervous but when Sadie Hawkins now was
the time it was easier for guys because
the girl had to ask you and then you got
the matching shirt and that was pretty
cool now that part was pretty cool when
you got that matching shirt because we
didn't have like you know when I was
growing up my mom would get us a nice
outfit and usually one pant and two
shirts at the beginning of school and
what I would do is sometimes I would
wear the pant the first day the second
day turned the pants inside out because
the inside looks a little bit of a
different color until people it was a
different pant a DP you know and uh and
anyway so yeah when so when you got the
girl that bought you that shirt that
Sadie Hawkins shirt I run one time this
this pretty well-off girl in our town
she was well off her name was Emily and
she was pretty and she was cute and she
was my friend and and she got me a nice
[ __ ] shirt bro dan that thing was
nice I'm a mutter armorer I put that
thing on dude I felt like I was like the
like just like the mayor's son or
something I felt like I was just a
little Fauntleroy to third or something
I just felt like I don't know who I felt
like I just we were putting it on and it
felt nice at three or four buttons and
the fabric was real strong and I
remember putting that [ __ ] on and just
feeling like a champion so that was the
nice thing about Sadie Hawkins you got
that free shirt now some of them you get
a poor girl would ask you and that [ __ ]
give you a damn tank top but uh you know
a little symbol about electricity or
something or one of those City handout
tank tops you know it says vote for
Jackson or something on the back of it
or vote for you know Walter some kind of
[ __ ] but
remember that Sadie Hawkins man it was
pretty enjoyable and and that was just
and it was this time of year that's when
it happened in the fall and it was just
madness walking around school just
waiting for a girl to ask you and then
it became closer and closer and closer
you're like damn everybody's been asked
now I'm like the last one man that [ __ ]
dude being young and going through like
moments like that is pretty it really
like it's such a it's so severe at the
time I mean at the time there was
nothing I mean I would get to school I
had to look clean I took you know look
nice I was like waiting for a woman to
ask me to the Sadie Hawkins
I want the free shirt from a rich girl
but more often than not bra
I'd end up with your girl thick TIFF
with those [ __ ] double dribble
kneecaps bruh the [ __ ] Reggie Miller
of orthopedics dude and she would uh you
know I get that you know just that
regular baby girl to ask me and one girl
asked me one day this one time though
does she get she carried me during one
of the dances see if I can really kind
of lifted me up and carry me and I
didn't know what to do man I didn't know
what to do except just get an erection
broca's that's when you're that young
you when you're you were you real y'all
you know when you're about 13 if you are
you get anything get you a rag I saw
somebody get electrocuted one time over
there about uh outside of the swagman
and I [ __ ] popped a bone or like what
the [ __ ] man you know like I mom like
I'm like I'm with that what is that
man's name electric manor like I'm
[ __ ] I don't know bro whatever but damn
yeah did when you were young now yeah it
now you does ain't no woman I wish they
still had Sadie Hawkins for adults I
think it would be nice wouldn't it be
cool to walk around town thinking and
somebody's gonna ask you to a dance and
I guess that it is still like that with
dates but I think in a small town it
would be really beautiful you know if
you're like okay Sadie Hawkins is coming
up in our town it's a fun thing that
everybody still celebrates so we're
gonna somebody gets to ask something so
you get to you know everybody's waiting
the girl's gonna come and you're waiting
but that was a fun time and those dances
and it was always around this time of
year around fall or autumn trying to
think of some other memories I have from
this time of year I really enjoyed when
I was young at this time you're getting
off the school bus in the afternoon
because the a it would be getting darker
earlier and sometimes there would be
like a little bit of wind and it would
be kind of a little chilly and it would
just I don't know there was possibility
in the air it was almost like
mother nature was was just about to tell
us a secret or something it just
something felt the time of year
something just felt really nice about it
you know before it got too cold or
before it got uncomfortable just I don't
know it's just something nice when the
air is just so it feels just as as alive
as you are it's like you guys met each
other
5050 because in the summer is so hottest
you know it's the world's meeting yet
like ninety five five and then the
winter is the same you know if you hang
out outside long enough outside will
kill you that's crazy to it in the
winter if you hang out out outside long
enough outside will kill you don't think
mother nature ain't a hit man that's
Shady Hawkins brought when she asks you
to die
mother nature asks you to die boy if
it's too cold out but there was that
special time of year and you know and um
in November right around you know
Halloween around this time and it was
just when the air was just kind of you I
don't know you'd be walking and
sometimes some leaves would blow right
up up in front of you they'd be behind
you but the wind would just pick him and
moving right in front of you and it just
felt like the world was walking with you
like there was magic in the air I love
that man I loved that and one thing
about living in Los Angeles you don't
get that you we there aren't any seasons
here so it gets to be very much a
Groundhog Day and and you think it's
nice but at a certain point sometimes
it's not that enjoyable because it's
just like oh that's nice again it's nice
again it's nice again you don't you
don't remember it's like ah
yeah it's just like uh it is you know
it's like I mean it's everybody says but
it's like Groundhog's Day but happy
November to you and thank you for being
here and just being a part of my life
today and I'm happy to be a part of your
life today and and I'm feeling good you
know I'm feeling hopeful and so that's
where I'm at and I'm happy to have those
feelings today and I feel you know I'm
just trying to feel grateful that I'm
wake up you know today and I'm feeling
good and and that you know just like you
know I'm gone well you know I'm tired of
just feeling like that just you know I
want the breeze to be at my back then
this nice man everything is okay and
it's gonna be that way we got some nice
calls that came in we're gonna talk
about a couple of different things
what did I do this weekend I wouldn't
did some yoga feeling good about that I
got a fever man I got a fever lie sign
at 1:00 a.m. and a fever I think a fever
is kind of fun I think cuz it's like you
get to take the nyquil you get to like
you get to make noises like that dude I
woke up until the night bro and I felt
like um I just
and it was sweat all under me and I'm
like [ __ ] bro I'm like a ocean I'm like
you know like Billy ocean or whatever
Frank ocean or whatever that guy's name
is Ron ocean or something I don't know
what his name is I think he's um he is a
musician I think he died actually but
but damn dude I was like [ __ ] I'm gonna
check on him on homes for [ __ ]
flounders for fish because with as much
water is flying out of my body right now
dude I wouldn't be surprised if
somebody's sitting you know if one of
the neighbors just you know Bates a hook
and just casts it
right out into my bellybutton because
I'm [ __ ] damp as hell I wouldn't be
surprised if somebody lays a couple of
hot trout lines out there but back
behind my freakin behold bruh back there
in that [ __ ] Fern Gully
cuz I'm growing some crops but I've got
some real serious body hair about my ass
so you know who I am son looks like my
buttholes making a little mitten back
there a little mitten maker speaking of
that actually manscaped look the
holidays is coming up and it is true
that if you don't take care of your
crotch 99% at a time nobody's gonna take
care of it for you support for this past
weekend which is this podcast comes from
manscaped who is number one in men's
below-the-belt grooming God dang they're
number one they're number one man I mean
that's that they're the damn San
Francisco 49ers of crotch cropper e brah
talk about talk about taking care of
yourself they can help you manscape this
forever changed
changing the grooming game with the
perfect package 2.0 dude if you may use
manscape you show somebody if you junk
out in the net out in the world or
something they might not even report you
for being a peep in town and say hey
damn that God takes care of his [ __ ] his
you know his dicks got that Brian
Bosworth bro he's got that real he gots
that buzz cut on his nuts that's
beautiful man let's not forget about the
crop preserver an anti chafing ball
deodorant they got it the perfect
package 2.0 includes boxer briefs that
keeps your junk cool and smelling fresh
you don't want that unfresh scent around
your ween and also the electric trimmer
is called the lawn mower and it's
waterproof and skin safe technology
protect you from nicking up your bag
everybody wants to be st. Nick but not
this time baby you don't want to Nick
your sack get 20% off and free shipping
with the code Theo th EO at manscaped
dot-com your balls will thank you get
20% off and free shipping with the code
th EO at manscaped comm that's 20% off
with Free Shipping at manscape comm use
code CEO Olivia a bear sent this patreon
question in she said hey Theo I mean I
made that part up she didn't say that
but I hear comedians use the word hacky
often what does that mean well hacky is
if a comedian telling a joke that you've
heard other people tell a lot or the
same type of premise a lot of times for
me when I go back and watch my own
material early material I say oh that's
real hacky that's real
anybody could do it that's how that's my
definition of it Oh anybody could do
that you know I remember when I started
out doing comedy I said I don't want to
sell jokes I want to sell you know I
want to I don't want people to remain on
to remember a joke when they leave I
want people to remember me I want them
to remember oh what what there was
something that guy I don't care if they
leave and they don't remember one of the
jokes that's not important I want that
because the jokes anybody could do a
joke you know a dead animal could do a
joke did if you write one you know you
write the first part of the joke on one
side of his body and then if you flip
him over and write the punchline then
every [ __ ] you know every Highway
armadillo could [ __ ] be Chris Rock
but what I'm saying is that I wanted to
be Burma I want to be to be oh I want to
sell myself I want to sell I want to I
want them to be like oh wow who was that
so I think one way of trying to be not
be hacky is by just creating things that
are true to you or follow your
sensibilities you know I look back on
some of my jokes and sometimes I say oh
that's kind of hacky I wouldn't do that
anymore
but then also you evolve it's really
interesting how you evolve in comedy I
mean I remember I used to do this bit
about Brad Pitt and when I met him
because I did meet him dude
the only Brad Pitt that God ever made
bro met his ass and and I remember after
I did that bit I think a man I will
never have a bit as good as that in my
whole life my career is over mom
how can I ever beat that or do as well
as that and now years later five years
later I can't even remember that bit I
can't remember it and it's and and and
to me I have bit said her her stories
that are far more interesting so but
hacky to me means oh anybody's I've
heard that a million times I've heard
that premise I've heard that joke an
example of a hacky joke is oh um
if you see the the the the comedian
using the mic stand as a penis as a
wiener if you see oh somebody say you
know sigh Alice for our penis medicine
or whatever
and they're always like a four hours
what am I gonna do with the penis for
four hours that's like a real popular
hacky joke and I remember telling her I
told that joke and I started everybody I
think sometime you just need to get your
footing and so and then I think there's
comedians that you tell hacky jokes I
think all of us some stuff is sometimes
all of us tell something hacky to other
people like Oh everybody will think
something that somebody else does is
hack but that's the answer there um
grace Jensen asked what's your plans for
Thanksgiving and what are your favorite
dish my plan is to go home to New
Orleans on to Louisiana and see my
family you know really I got five
beautiful nieces and nephews and three
siblings
and uh and she said and what is your
favorite dish you know I like them sweet
potatoes I like them sweet potatoes do
when I was young we had to had a cat in
our neighborhood this cat quagmire was
his name and he was he wasn't black but
he was definitely one of his parents was
black at least and he man he had sharp
nails
he had sharp nails and I used to love
one thing I like to do when I was young
I liked to take my shirt off you know a
lot of times to show appreciation to
people or to just you know a lot of
times if somebody did something real
cool or something you'd take your
[ __ ] shirt off and show him your
chest you know do a firework if you had
it but if you didn't have a firework you
just show him that [ __ ] you just hit
him with that [ __ ] that baby bird you
know and Quagmire was this cat and
somebody had sharpened his nails in the
neighborhood and I don't know who did it
people say so this guy did it but you
know probably somebody that was an
alcoholic or a lonely woman
so but anyway and I remember I sometimes
I would lay down and they would put him
on my back and he would [ __ ] walk on
your back dude and it was like very much
like a um not like a torture chamber but
man it was know what it was like Eastern
medicine
what's that call were somebody that's
not really a doctor but like kind of
dresses like one [ __ ] tries to show
you oh Jesus my brain is just I was full
of trans fat I think a Roma that no
Apothic you know what I'm saying it's
that thing where the guy it's like
playing darts but it's [ __ ] a bunch
of darts and nobody's keeping score
really except that nothing maybe Chinese
people are kind of but
ba-ba-ba-ba esthetician no aromatherapy
no what is it called and they [ __ ]
put you in a room by yourself a lot of
time they turn the lights out they put
all the [ __ ] inside of you exorcism and
that's what it felt like dude was
exorcism and uh and damn boy that
[ __ ] cat had the sharpest nails you
know I said I think they put other nails
in him I swear to God he he he [ __ ]
hit a couple of thumbtacks in his own
little paws like he'd been in prison or
something or like priests own you know
French prison because that dude he would
get on my [ __ ] back bro and God dang
dude I would see the future boy and I
would [ __ ] feel it man I mean he just
took my brain in a warp zones when
quagmire would just run up and down my
back but here was the thing though after
he would do it for a while he would eat
a sweet potato at his cat and he would
eat a sweet potato right there in front
of you and I never in all my days I
never seen anything like this do when
you see a little beautiful little dark
[ __ ] just huffing down a patate broad
one of them orange Poe tots dog I've
never seen anything like that in my life
still makes my [ __ ] horse swell up
God dang
praise God bro but yeah I like sweet
potatoes okay let's get into a couple of
other questions here Oh Nick went to the
fights Nick went to the Logan Paul ksi
fight so a lot of people don't know
Logan Paul he's the you know he's like a
YouTube guy and he's a and he was in
here he came in here and he was I
thought he's really gracious young man
and he and he the dude is very
successful and he decided to box and he
went into another boxing match and he
fought ksi man and this is the British
and y'all know look dude the British bro
I'm not against him but we left there we
left Britain because
or England we left England because it
wasn't working out so you know it's like
it's like you know it's it's you know we
were that we did it we did it and that's
why we came over here to start a new
England you know and try to revamp it
and make it more dope but um anyway they
fought and I want to talk with him I
want to talk with Nick cuz Nick went to
the fight producer Nick and I were gonna
get him in and then we got some great
calls about LSU wood mill gypsies
stepsons premature uncles and and
methamphetamines so this past weekend
has brought to you--by Skillshare and
Skillshare it's it's we all need skills
think about somebody that doesn't have
any skills man who what are they usually
somebody that's just you know just
walking around looking for something
maybe somebody that's playing kickball
but without a ball and without anybody
else so you have to have skills
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators creators with
more than 25,000 classes and design
business and more you'll discover
countless ways to fuel your curiosity
creativity and career take classes in
social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing and
illustration skill share is a great
thing a great gift to get somebody they
don't know what they want to do give
them a million options they want to do
something online they don't know what it
is get them this hitter graphic design
graphic design basics core principles
for visual design join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for my
listeners get two months of Skillshare
free that's right
Skillshare is offering tpw listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
25,000 classes for free go to Skillshare
comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare dot-com / Theo
von I got some tour dates coming up I'm
gonna tell them to you right now they
are I will be in Lafayette Louisiana at
the Heyman Center and that's almost sold
out with uh we're gonna have proceeds
benefiting Dustin Poirier good fight
Foundation down there so I'm excited to
do something fun in Louisiana and that's
almost sold out over there about two
thousand people coming in we got The
Wiltern in Los Angeles December tenth
and then after that I'll be in
Manchester Dublin Ireland Glasgow London
London London Amsterdam Oslo in Norway
there are still tickets available for
London Oslo and Stockholm this week
tickets for Toronto Oxon Hill Maryland
and New Jersey we'll all go on sale so
and now imma do that little rendition
for y'all misbehaving by baby Billy and
Amy Lee mama told me not to I did it
anyway misbehaving daddy said don't but
I said I'm gonna misbehaving paws on the
windowsill swimming in the creek
catching crawled dads and playing with a
stick I wore lipstick and I got caught
shaving just to little country kids
outside misbehaving so that's a little
bit of that free all for free right
there all right what's up Nick what's
cracking dude you went to the fight
minute cuz I texted the other day at
what's going on you seem that picture
mm-hmm you sent me that imagery from the
fight man yeah ksi Logan Paul the the
big rematch when you got there what was
the energy like kind of walking into the
place did it seem like the typical
energy going into like a boxing match
did it feel like going to a performance
kind of what was it was dead right away
so we the main card started at six there
four fights on it and we got there right
at six and just no one cared about the
fights that were going on and the first
one of the of the main card was Billy
Joe
Saunders who's an undefeated boxer like
he's a legitimate pro he won by knockout
he may fight Canelo next and let him
just no one gives a [ __ ] there in the
stadium no one care so was it almost
awkward that that was it almost seemed
like they were fighting and people were
just like on their phones and like 100%
there's so many people's if so many
wannabe influencers and stuff and then
there were some that were popular I
didn't recognize any of them but they'd
walk down the stairs and like a rush of
kids would like flood over to them as
the fights were going on like though the
fight could have ended and no one would
have noticed wow it was it was a scene
oh dang and did you feel out of place as
like an actual kind of fight fan do you
feel what was the age vibe in there what
was some of that it was it was really
mixed I mean they were definitely a huge
portion of young kids that you wouldn't
normally see it I see it a fight a lot
of parents who you could tell like they
were just like dragged there and like
didn't know what was going on but then
they were like it seemed like there were
some real fight fans but they're just
like sitting there watching the fight
you know it's not like they're not
making a big scene or whatever anybody
who was there for like Logan Paul fight
like I don't know you could pick him out
okay I see we're saying so there's a
couple of fight fans there but not that
many yeah and the ones that were there
were just chilling enjoying the fight
they weren't like it was an all rowdy
because the energy just wasn't there so
the energy that wasn't there throughout
what was it like whatever his fight
started that fight it was it was like
bumpin the crowd went wild
he had like a mix of boos and cheers but
I think I think for the most part there
was a lot of Logan Paul chance and it
was like Pro him because it was like USA
over England KS is from Great Britain or
whatever yeah and did uh did you see um
was it was there a lot of action was it
good boxing or was it [ __ ] boxing the
the first two fights like I said they
were legitimate boxers real boxing
contenders the main event with ksi and
Logan it was Logan he lost the fight by
split decision which we haven't said but
he looked like a real boxer to me and he
looked like the better boxer for sure
ksi he had a he had a ton
stamina and he was constantly winging
throwing huge punches but like Logan
looked pretty technical to be honest it
didn't look horrible the fight right
before it I was like this weird filler
fight and it looked like who was on the
fight car before it the fight right
before it yeah I'm thinking it was
[ __ ] like I'm just trying to think of
who would be on there dude was it like
um Thomas the Train versus [ __ ]
scooby-doo or yeah
these those guys have way more clout
than the guys that fight I think it was
just some weird filler fight and they
look like weird versions of doppelganger
of ksi and Logan Paul it was like this
kid with like frosted tips and that this
other black guy I my theory was they did
it to get people were in the hallway
like back to their seats Wow so if you
saw it on the TV Beck oh my god it
started
did it feel overly produced was there a
lot of produced stuff like I noticed
just watching some of it like you know
they had like a lot of advertisements
and stuff did it feel like that or did
it feel just like they got out there and
that in it and that's when the fight hit
I mean it was I figure a lot of hold up
for advertisements is for me I didn't
notice a lot of holdups for
advertisement specifically I mean the
walkouts
took a long time but like in big boxing
matches that's kind of the thing it was
promoted by a real boxing promotion
Eddie Hearn who's like he's been around
actual boxing for a long time so it kind
of had that same feel and the pacing of
it but I didn't notice the
advertisements in the arena and he also
didn't know it's kind of hard watching
boxing when you're in the arena because
you don't see everything and like Logan
Paul a huge moment was in the fourth
round he Nakia side down but part of the
punches he was holding his head and
doing uppercuts and they took points
away and you knew something was going on
but no one announced in the arena what
happened so you're I I didn't even know
why and why is that oh because you're
there as opposed to hearing it on
television
yeah then where you can you the
announcers are telling you what's
happened yeah yeah they're getting told
by producers what the judges just did
and then they report it to the people
watching at home but yeah you didn't
know and it's really hard to scored
because they I tried to focus on the
actual ring rather than watching the
screen which you sometimes do when
you're at like a big event and but it's
hard to see what lands and stuff so I
had no idea what the decision was gonna
be once the fight was over mostly males
in the audience there oh yeah oh yeah I
mean there was the in
- gram women influencers you could see
like speckled throughout but yeah it was
it was all dudes and was it mostly
straight man you think a lot of more gay
it was or some gay men or somewhat it
seemed like I think they were they they
tried to present themselves as straight
but who knows there's a lot of really
really tight pants and and that whole
vibe just uh the Instagram fashion so I
don't know who knows a lot of fashion
Nova or something they call it I brought
I brought a lady oh really prove yeah
yeah she loved it too is she did yeah
even if girls aren't don't think they're
fans of fighting they love going to
fights live yeah you know that's that's
interesting yet cuz I was um yeah when I
went to the Poirier fight I took a girl
that I was singing and yes should they
loved it no what do they love about
anything I don't know I think I
aphrodisiac just men all the
testosterone pumping I think it's the
violence mmm-hmm yeah something yeah the
energy yeah I guess probably cuz there's
so much much ease mo going on it makes
them they they probably feel more
feminine because they're like yeah you
know they're the opposite side of that
the sweat pheromones and all that and
were you guys close enough to get any
sweat on you or anything like that no we
we had good good seats the shadow to our
little twink friend Gianni he was the
one who hooked it up oh really
through his a publicist Cassie yeah yeah
so we had pretty good lower lower bowl
seats and we're we were wrote Jay off
the floor so it was like we're straight
on with uh with the ring or whatever
that's awesome man yeah I was at a date
you took yeah yeah you guys we're
matching shirts if you ever heard of
Sadie Hawkins dance
hey I'm familiar with Sadie Hawkins the
girls ask the guys it's a little country
[ __ ] loved that cuz dude I had such
bad acne every time I went near a girl I
was like oh my god dude there's no way
she's gonna say yes if there was like a
real dance you know so it was always so
much easier when the girls had to ask
the guys did you get asked with your
acne yeah I got asked by another girl
had pretty bad acne and that was almost
[ __ ] is so sad girls an act with acne
are smart to go after though I mean
that's gonna clear up that's that's an
ugly duckling
waiting to happen yeah man but I wasn't
trying to
you know years you know what I wasn't
about at least be nice to him you know
she was awesome she was smart we just
both had acne so then I'm like uh [ __ ]
we're the [ __ ] acne group like and
that's back when they had oxy pads
member oxy pads oh yeah it was like this
[ __ ] hot pad at bleach or something
your face it [ __ ] hurt so bad those
commercials made him look like magic I
like I wasn't young enough to old enough
to have acne when I saw the commercials
but I wanted him it was not magic wait
I'm a robber clean my shoes dude I had a
friend that looked totally different
after use one bro if I can move one of
his eyes over to the side this [ __ ] was
very I mean you could easily do remodel
you were like you had black face on this
whole time dude they have ceedric what
else we got any good news stuff yeah
there's some some wildness going down
because of the popeyes chicken sandwich
in Maryland specifically a 28 year old
man was stabbed to death they didn't
release the names but it was in an
altercation after he cut the line well
let me say this if y'all if y'all
fighting that Popeyes but look I grew up
around New Orleans and they got a st.
Charles over there st. they got the
Popeyes over there on st. Charles Avenue
and every Mardi Gras you know a couple
people pop off over there and gun each
other down over a couple of biscuits so
what I'm saying is I know how good
Popeyes is but y'all gotta [ __ ]
tighten up man
I can't lose y'all [ __ ] you got to
compose yourself in the car before you
go in there you know it's a chicken
sandwiches this it's that dude who gives
a [ __ ]
Popeyes not even a real person man and
it's [ __ ] anyway and you know half
the people in Popeyes a lot of them have
[ __ ] guns and weapons so if you're
going in there to eat man it's risky
[ __ ] you know it's basically like the
Vietnam or [ __ ] fast food man so I
think you have to really I don't know it
almost seem like you should take
self-defense before you go in there to
get some I mean they had a guy they had
they had a rubenesque gentleman the
other day I think it might have even
been a you know kind of a tender
gentleman bodies
a senior citizen woman your god in a
parking lot at a [ __ ] Popeyes do what
are you holding two winters what are
y'all doing that's what I'm saying Brian
you got to bring [ __ ] May snook if I
go into a Popeyes dude I'm having one
thing [ __ ] that spray on butter which
I bring in there anyway when I go and
then one thing in that spray or mace
dude only give a [ __ ] if I mix them up
dude is spicy anyway in there you got
any closing thoughts on the Popoff stuff
just that like you said you just never
know who you're gonna be hustling with
like most people in Popeyes have guns so
like someone cuts the line let him cut
the line oh I saw I do [ __ ] cooker
cook cook I saw I do [ __ ] cook a
drumstick with a [ __ ] 38 was it's
crazy I mean it was frozen and if I can
put 19 bullets into knit that thing was
just beautiful hot but stay safe out
there man r.i.p bro rest and pawpaws doe
what else we got
so the Nationals after their World
Series win visited the White House and
the highlight the thing that made all
the headlines was Kurt Suzuki Don dumb
make America great again hat and down
shrub came up and gave him a hug from
behind it was it was really cute scene
oh I love them and it's cool bro dude I
love I hope that Hillary gets back into
the election I just I love the politics
is getting so [ __ ] good it's like
reality TV Donald Trump's gonna be in
his late 70s after through the second
term think about that like [ __ ] is gonna
get weird I just think and it's all but
everything is becoming like the WWE now
everything is becoming just hype it's
all hype it's kind of becoming every man
for themselves I feel like or woman or
closeted lesbian but it's like everybody
it's everybody for themselves this
shit's gonna get [ __ ] good dude yeah
that's what you got to do you got to be
able to remove yourself from it and just
just watch it like go vote do your thing
but other than that just take it all in
because yeah the next year is going to
be a it's going to get vicious
oh I wonder if there will be any I start
to wonder and it's so [ __ ] funny brah
dude I really like do I love watching
Donald Trump Junior's son dude that dude
is [ __ ] to me he's very very funny a
lot of times some of the [ __ ] that he
posts online but I mean I just think
politicians it's just such an outdated
thing it feels like to me um but it's
just getting great you see like Kanye
West is gonna run as supposedly in 2024
you know he's Jesus Christ I mean
everything does this everything's going
on and he's a republic I mean I just I
don't know man in a lot of ways it's
really an exciting time because here's
what I think no matter what they're
doing I keep my head down I do my [ __ ]
no politician has ever done anything
from me dude none of them I don't care
what color or creed or whatever they're
from black white fillin even or whatever
dog I don't none of them do not never so
you do your [ __ ] I'm grateful to live in
a country where I can do my [ __ ] and for
the most part people will leave you
alone you know one of my favorite like
thing that's really just stuck in my
head from our episodes is when we had
Duncan Trussell on and he was quoting
some like philosopher book I can't
remember but the idea was tend to the
garden you can touch so just like effect
what you can around you and like you
said like no politician has ever done
anything for you directly go out and
vote because that makes some effect but
I earn that you have to get up go to
work do like try to accomplish your
goals what have you yeah yeah you know
there's people I think there's once you
for me once you start thinking a
politician is gonna change your life I
feel like you've already lost I feel
like and some people I think you know a
lot of times it can be an excuse people
aren't happy with what's going on in
their existence or something so they
really get into politics to try and put
the hook over there you know and sort of
but I mean we all find ways to not look
at ourselves but dude I hope this [ __ ]
ends in a Royal Rumble dude I want
everybody in the ring bro
I want Trump I want Hillary I want
[ __ ] dirty Epstein on him too [ __ ]
that dude uh hopefully Jionni can get me
tickets he's a real wild guy um who else
speaking of publicist Jordan Peterson's
publicist came out to the comedy show
this week oh that's fine which was
pretty cool she said that he is still in
treatment and that he's doing well and
that uh maybe we would cross podcasts
again when he came out got two that was
a great episode yeah man that was pretty
cool man that was pretty cool
teacher said don't but I said it in
anyway misbehaving preacher said no if
you do you're gonna pay misbehaving
kicking and spitting and cussing out
loud running through the house what a
pickle in my mouth
play it in the street look at me outside
waving just to little country kids
outside Miz behaving all right what do
you got brother so ABC footage was
released from a hot mic of an anchor amy
robach and she was caught saying that
ABC made her squashed the story she had
on Jeffrey Epstein that she had over
three years ago she was quoted as saying
in the hot mic I've had the story for
three years we would not put it on air
it was unbelievable we had Clinton we
had everything and just a couple days
ago a 25 year old producer Amy Bianco
was accused of being a whistle
whistleblower and allegedly leaked being
the one to leak the video though she
denies it hmm Elise how much play the
word whistleblowers get in this year
baffling amount of play every year some
word picks up steam like that yeah
yeah I mean what amazes me is just the
hypocrisy of a lot of networks it's like
we have to help we have to be you know
we have to be open to you know doing the
right thing you got to do the right
thing you got to be supportive and you
got to support diversity and you got a
but then once why would they not let it
out I wonder I mean the maybe too many
people were tied in that had money
involved yeah that's got that's like the
the theory for sure but once it comes
back to that bottom line man people
don't want it to you know
it's interesting it's like once it comes
to when it's going to effect really your
pocketbook and stuff how do you the
choice do you make then yeah man these
networks are dangerous and the news wins
if we go to war if people go to war
people are fighting people are [ __ ]
shooting each other up for a shrimp
biscuit out there at the pea pods bruh
the news win they win every time because
then it's just people are gonna tune in
there to see what's going on I believe
that the news has zero interest of
anybody ever being at peace anymore I
don't think that that that just doesn't
sell anymore for them it doesn't seem
like so it's just a dangerous it's
dangerous what we let into ourselves you
know and it's hard not to me some of
that's fun too but but um but they don't
care about you I don't feel like the
news networks I don't feel like they
care about informing us do you feel that
way no like I think if you take the
individual people that work for the
organizations they they might start out
like altruistic alee and hoping to make
change and stuff but at the end of the
day the decision makers are the people
who are worried about the bottom line so
and I don't even think it's like
nefarious they're trying to do good for
their companies so their employees can
do well all that but you still when you
go after like ratings that's what
creates more money and why you started
gets lost in it yeah
Epstein man unbelievable unbelievable
how long that guy was operating
pedophile it's crazy it's it's it's
unbelievable because a lot of people
have I mean I just don't know I just
don't know when you really really think
about like you just like a pedophile you
see huge pedophile it makes you sick if
you really think about what he was doing
yeah it's just just so twisted man it's
the dark arts bro and they're alive man
I think that's good Nick word I
appreciate it man thanks for checking
out that fight yeah totally all right
that's the real Nick Davis we want to
get a few submits
for single moms down there in Lafayette
and that would be December 26 I'm going
to do something nice for a couple of
local Louisiana single mothers so if
there's a special lady that you know
down there who is a good woman who's got
our children or to a children now I
don't want I don't don't bring me an 80
year old lady with a 60 year old child I
want a mother you know and I mean maybe
I'm being rude by saying what I want but
that's what I wanted and we're gonna do
something nice for them and make them a
part of that evening so you can hit the
hotline ninety five six six four nine
five zero three to do to submit all
right let's take a couple of calls that
we got here and thank you guys for being
here with me today
what's up Theotis is Austin from a key
road in Covington Austin over there from
Covington Louisiana and that's my
hometown and you know they have the
tallest statue of Ronald Reagan there in
Covington Louisiana and that's 12-foot
of Ronald Reagan sheer made out of
copper or something pewter I think it's
actually pewter which is just kind of
like dirty copper bra it's like coppers
a little [ __ ] brother that had to get
shipped off to school you know like a
special school but um but anyway and
Ronald Reagan never visited our town
either but we still got that statue for
him bro Ron ray boy Ron reggae get all
right let's get it brother I'm just
calling to get your thoughts on the LSU
win over Alabama and uh what'd you think
about coach Owens over oh hi again dang
bro um you know it's so funny I was
watching that game and at the beginning
they were showing jobber oh and he you
know he's a handsome guy and he's the
quarterback of LSU and he's potential
Heisman
he's the probably the Heisman
front-runner for the Heisman Trophy and
he looked you know is like oh he's at
you know he's doing well that's how he
looked and he
look confident at the end of the game
somebody I think he died they were
interviewing them and stuff and he he
had a different look to him he looked
like well for one they look like a
winner but he looked like he evolved a
little bit like he was something he was
bigger than he was when the game started
he was he was more iconic he was more I
mean he'll a duty was even a little
handsomer looking at then he was just
there was more I don't know he was just
he'd been through something you know
it's interesting Dustin Poirier said a
lot of time and he's a UFC guy and and
so he's telling me sometimes when you go
and eat when you're in these fights
whether you win or lose you you you
leave part of yourself in there and
sometimes you take part of yourself out
of there and and it's just interesting
what happens with mango in a battle of
some sort or when we go through
something in our lives a lot of times we
really do an experience can really
change us and really change us really
add to us hurt or deplete from us
and I remember seeing him after the game
looking at Joe Byrne but like man that
that guy is gonna be a leader he just
had this different quality about him
that he gained through that win
go Tigers man yeah it was uh I'm glad
that they got to play a lot of times you
it's just so hard to get these this
college these conferences they put all
these games together and a lot of time
and a lot of dog [ __ ] I like to see the
good games and so I'm glad they had the
good games number one versus number two
they should play almost every other week
who's number one who's number two let
him play you got number one playing
verse number nine hundred who gives it
am i druther [ __ ] drink lemonade bruh
I'd rather drink eliminated through a
straw to my own ass dude you know I'd
rather smoke a bowl Damone freakin dick
dawg I ain't doing all that [ __ ]
every week number one verse number six
do something you have the numbers you
know who people are ranked and has
stayed you out here you got number seven
verse number six thousand and it's just
a damn you know water for the blind
technical school or something from
outside of Minneapolis and also shout
out to those Golden Gophers boy
Minnesota bruh that team has played so
hard for so long they had to deal with
the Vikings
sharing a feel with them for a few years
they've done so much and uh man that was
really really exciting and man I wanted
to see Oklahoma get beat by Iowa State
just because our Iowa I think it was
Iowa State it was I was state just
because I like that underdog man but
Jalen hurts man I like what he's doing
Jaden Jalen Jalen I think I like what
he's doing over there
it's an exciting it's coming down and be
exciting Baylor's and there's a lot of
exciting teams you're rolling up into it
so and dude they talked about us on our
on SportsCenter I put it on Instagram
and that was about the craziest thing
ever
they had a man named HAMP Sisson over
there Furman University and he ran a
ball and he had a good block he had a
really good block and shot out ham
sitting over there and and the Sports
Center the guy said something HAMP shot
out the ovine I thought that was pretty
cool man because you know I used to
[ __ ] pedal them low hamsters bungee
pigs out there off highway 190 over
there about a snowball stand my pads
video and shrimp all right let's take
another call over here nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three hey
what else video is Dustin from
Monticello Arkansas
what's up Dustin and Monticello Arkansas
that sounds like a unique little spots I
think I've been there before
let me see something about it marker
Monticello Arkansas 71,000 people it
says over there Monticello and and
Monticello
is rodney shelton Foss is from
Monticello who was potentially the first
American killed in World War two so if
you don't know that then now you know it
that's over there Monticello okay what
do we got brother all word and man I
just had a question I got this job now
and that would mill you know cutting
some law oh yeah you that [ __ ] birch
bad boy son you'd have [ __ ] a little
log jacker you that [ __ ] pine bro you
freaking Peter pine dude straight out
the gate past the last startled morning
bro I'll see you in the Lost Boys bro
Captain Hook brah freakin ganga rang dog
let me see what you got you working at
the wood mill what's up and man
day after day it's and where's my body
down didn't to a point I can't even be
happy no more going into work
I just going to work broken down and I
can't stop thinking about leaving they
go by a slow so I was wondering that you
got me pissed first a and happy at a job
that so physically demanding eyes gay
man you know
I think that job is training you for
something better man for something is
gonna go through in your life you're
gonna need the experience you're gonna
need to be a tough man you know they say
iron sharpens iron or iron I think it is
iron sharpens iron yeah so yeah man
instead of life doesn't happen to us it
happens for us so we you know if it's
physically the man is building you up
you know you ain't no soft boss bro
you ain't no q-tip you ain't no little
cotton puff you something this special
y'all daddy do not so I say you [ __ ]
go in there and get it done you got
woodchuck bring a gun in there something
bring a knife dude be like Donatello or
something knife that [ __ ] out dude I
think you should put weights on your
legs and build your legs up dude leg
lifts while you in there do knee jackers
or whatever bill Jass build your neck do
you could come out of there looking like
you know looking like damn um Andre 3000
or Andre the Giant you could do it all
man that's what I'm saying is you got
the opportunity man this is just
sharpening you for something else
whatever is going on right now is
getting you ready for the next thing and
look throw a podcast on you know
sometimes it's like you know I always
think like man I have to do this today
instead of thinking man I get to do this
this is it
this is life this is it and I know it's
not easy man I'm not preaching at you
you know I'm right there with you man
it's tell everything everything
everything can be grueling
but we don't have to go to work we get
to there's somebody somewhere would love
to work in a wood mill think about it
you're Santa's Little Helper man all
those little boys up there he's got
those little high [ __ ] little little
people up there smoking them big Giants
bra them big [ __ ] Pony pieces and
building little trains and [ __ ] build a
train build a wooden cannon you got an
opportunity but you got all of that wood
sounds like you got a
the opportunity on your hands build the
world's largest birdhouse next thing you
know you got six thousand birds out
there in your yard next thing you know
you got a zoo next thing you know you
got money coming in and you got a couple
of [ __ ] zeebee out there a couple zoo
[ __ ] you feel me so but yeah man you
stay healthy stay hydrated listen to
some good podcast throw on some Coco
Diaz he'll get you through the day
[ __ ] but you can do it man I know
you can't keep your head up guy let's
take another call right here here we go
see yo what's up man is this Duggan
Blake um we had a run-in now running
with some gypsies here in Augusta
Georgia man I just didn't know like you
know if you ever had any you ever had a
run-in with a gypsy and if so how'd you
get out of that you know situations that
we're kind of we're kind of in it now on
just what you know appreciate your
insight man blood the show again cush
girl
gypsies man I tell you a lot of people
don't know about gypsies in America and
they got them ROM nichelle gypsies and
some people they have him on the white
they have a fighting show where it's
like gypsies fighting or something and
everybody gets a wedding dress in and a
fist fight outside of a Best Western and
I can't remember the name of it first
gypsies wedding or best gypsy or
something but what I'm telling you is
this man there's a unique subculture of
people our culture of people in America
called gypsies and they got a unique
wood they got their own style of living
man they marry gypsies a lot of times
they're real you know it's not
inbreeding or whatever just like
teamwork they're real family-oriented
family first
you know the husband's like to make the
money they all a lot him work in asphalt
and nice down the sub bruh cush girl and
they got their own language out there
and you see him up there Ohio and
Minnesota Milwaukee they got him out
there I met I fell out and where was
that guy he brought me a in Madison
Wisconsin
this guy did asphalt and he brought me a
orange have green hat they are out there
and they do asphalt and some of them
they pull their pulling the wool over
our over people's eyes and some of them
is legit businessman so really they're
just like everybody but if you have to
deal with them I think just I think a
lot of it for them is probably about
respect you know I was just I would try
to have a new experience if you've had a
rough experience to begin with I would
try to have a new experience with them
so hey look we might have got off to a
rough foot I'm willing to give things a
new shot what do you want to do now
sometimes gypsies they'll tell you
they're gonna do asphalt and stuff and
they just spray-paint your yard a black
or something until you dated asphalt and
they run off or something but but I
think a lot of that stuff's kind of
changing but you just got to keep your
head open and your eyes you know kind of
clear and everything and but yeah be
safe
also dude speaking of a gust I'm trying
to go to the I'm trying to take my
stepdad to the what does it call that
thing
masters I'm trying to take my stuff that
to the Masters next year because he's
getting older and always promised him I
would take them if anybody have an
insight on how it can get tickets to
that or badges to it let me know good
luck out there with them ROM Michels
bruh because they wild too and a lot of
them have long stomach a lot of a
gypsies have real long stomach a lot of
the women they put a little jewel in her
stomach like it was uh remember those
little dolls they had that you would
stick your pencil in the bottom with the
hair with the bright hair they have that
that magic belly space okay let's take
another call here nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three is the
hotline hey you know this is Alex from
Utah I have a serious issue
then what struggling with lately and
could use a second opinion on better I
have been divorced for a minute I have a
little girl with my first wife but I'm
getting remarried okay so you've been
divorced you have a little girl with the
first wife and you're getting remarried
Oh word and she has a little boy who's
now too now here's my problem I love the
boy we've been together for a long time
now so I love him he loves me he looks
at me and calls me dad either when I
look at him sometimes I see her
ex-husband and it's uh it'll throw me
off for a date now it's been hard to get
over that where you know I don't see
myself in him at all of us kind of weird
because I have this daughter that I do
of course because I have it with my ex
anyways man maybe I just need to suck it
up and know that it'll get well over
time but when I do stops me anyways love
your problem you brother thanks man
thank you for for the for this first
share in this experience that you're
going through man I can imagine that's
tough and that's a real situation you
know and I think it's a great chance
and look I'm not speaking like I know
everything I don't know anything but I
will say this it's a great opportunity
for you to be loving you know as hard as
it is as hard as it might be in certain
moments you sound like a loving person
you know because if sometimes he might
feel that that boy you look at him a
certain way you see a stepfather in him
and you know I'm sure the stepfather and
the mother made that child out of love
so it's a real opportunity for you to
look at him and just be loving you know
the only way he gets into the world is
through that woman in that man that's
the only way that boy gets into the
world and he might change the world you
know he might have met a new kind of
chocolate or something he might make you
know he might find a way to make pudding
even better he may colonize Mars that
might be the boy that does it he might
be that magic boy and you get a chance
to love him man you know and that's
pretty cool you know who knows maybe you
and your wife you don't even be able to
have a boy and so that's gonna be your
son and I'm sure the dad is probably a
little envious two of you in some ways
because imagine he probably looks at the
son and his son and sees that his son
really cares about you so it's really a
you know it's just an opportunity to
- just try and be loving and if you're
really having trouble I would just ask
you know try and ask your higher power
for to help you not have those feelings
of uncomfort anymore
ask them that they'd be taken away from
you but I think you got this brother
I'm a matter of fact man I know you got
it I've no doubt be good yourself bud
all right all right let's take another
call here here we go hey what's up steel
it's Joey from Ames Iowa you know I just
wanted to call and give you some good
news man I became an uncle a couple
weeks ago and I got a niece and she was
about a month early she looked like a
little banana pepper when she was born
but she's still beautiful man oh yeah
you got that early nice all work the
crazy thing is she's named after me I'm
Joseph and they called her Josephine so
I got that made me feel good man that
was some good [ __ ] but now I have to be
a role model amber that's all right you
know I just want to let you know give
you a little good news I know you get a
lot of come on drama and bad news on the
hotline so I just wanted to give you
something positive Joey got that
Josephine bra so they got a little baby
out there that little [ __ ] banana
pepper out there out there in Iowa and
look you you can be a rope I mean the
dad has to be the role model I think you
get to be awesome as [ __ ] bro you get to
get a Corvette you got to show up be
really cool don't be a creep
don't be a PDF file those are really
your responsibilities cuz you're gonna
get entrusted with the children from
time to time to spend time with them get
them snacks take them to a film do a you
know do something nice at Christmas you
know be loving from afar you get to be
like the escape that they'll have
sometimes from their parents like a cool
person to spend time with just make sure
there's nothing wrong with you mentally
or emotionally where you going to be you
know a pervert or pervert or anything
because that's what happens a lot of
times uncles will become sadly pedia
files and/or pee files or whatever
and I ain't doing that [ __ ] and praise
God I'm not she'd be good out there Joe
I appreciate the call brother let's take
another call here here we go
hey CEO this is a Thomas daddy from Fort
Worth Texas
Oh Tommy out of folk worse well I'm
calling today because a buddy of mine is
well I don't think addicted but I think
getting a little bit too much into best
he has been a little too much into meth
ok onward kind of dabbling in the mess
here in there I don't think it does
oh you mean he's messing around uh okay
I'll stop everyday but you know every
couple of weekends or so I find out this
dudes doing wrecks you know not like I
didn't you told me about it and I tell
him it's not fully exposed stop doing
that slippery slope I don't think that's
a great thing either hard work and do
the good job
whatnot he's a great guy that's great if
you want to do card tricks outside of uh
you know it's not a supermarkets for
people to make a couple of bucks for the
rest of your life
then meths great meth great if you want
to you know if you want to wash your
hands so much that you washed your damn
skin right off of them
then meth great that's great if you want
it to be wintertime and you don't need a
coat
because your body is at about 190
degrees then yeah that's great
all word just doesn't matter you know
and a couple of my friends have
approached me about it said that they're
worried about it cuz he's not really shy
about the fact that he does it he's
never really offered but you know if he
did it a weekend or two ago he did it
that day before him and hang out with us
he'll tell us each other I don't think
that's weird
well telling he's like the most
confident meth guy I ever really like
he's [ __ ] Muhammad Ali dude this
guy's you know smoked like a butterfly
shoot like a beet it's dudes on that
meth but he's fearless about it so he
might mean here's the here's the things
that can happen he could become the
greatest math user of all time and
really
become a champion of the sport you know
he could become the Deion Sanders of
methamphetamines or or
this dude could get caught in a
playground taking apart the slides and
the swings in the middle of the night
for no reason
so those are
really the two options let me hear a
little bit more so what would you do how
would you tell your friend then maybe
stop doing the mess thanks love you love
you too man I appreciate the call you
know because it is hard to approach
people especially if you think they have
addiction if they're struggling it's
hard also sometimes I remember I used to
use drugs and I would think other people
were using drugs too much did I erm erm
being high on cocaine and telling
somebody on cocaine bro you got to do
less cocaine like what bro you all
you're on cocaine I said all right right
I would I would maybe talk to an
interventionist man sometimes they cost
money but I would maybe talk to an
interventionist because it's still I
just don't see how it can get better
unless something happens now I'm just
really worried that it could get really
get bad quit so you gotta tighten him up
dude put little cards around to say no
meth you know knock knock who's there
not meth or start teaching that dude
algebra bro and come out with a new
thing called mathematics and this dude
is just a straight-up you know he's the
it's like a beautiful mind bro but with
methamphetamines and he's out there
doing it right and winning contests and
[ __ ] and winning trophies and traveling
around the world and smoking meth and
you know doing rails of meth and [ __ ]
setting new prizes and being a wizard
and everything and then he [ __ ] falls
in love with a girl somewhere in Japan
or something and then her father
probably kills him or something that's a
just and that's like a best-case
scenario
so it's limited man is limited
opportunity I think for him so I do
think it's a good time probably to speak
to him and and it is time to shut it
down man there's never a bad time to
shut down somebody's Matthews
because meth is like it's there's only
one or two drugs at the real end of the
line you got math and you got smoking
crack
nobody's ever been like oh yeah I'm
smoking meth and I also
you
and I also just you know won a Nobel
Prize nobody's doing that so you got to
get your boy off that meth I would talk
to him and if that's not working then I
would immediately talk to an
interventionist talk to someone who
works at a at a Narcotics Anonymous
group somebody who could actually speak
to him but I'd find somebody maybe in
recovery who can maybe talk to him if
you can't reach him because somebody
should be able to reach him and here's
the thing when he gets better man when
he's not using it he will thank you and
that's just a suggestion dude also I
don't [ __ ] know all right let's take
one last call man thank you guys for
being a part of this uh this show here
this week the holidays are coming it's
that special time of year it's a special
time of year we get to be alive for the
holidays man that's beautiful ain't
nobody in a world not excited about
Thanksgiving coming up getting that yeah
I'm a senior somebody from your family
that's you know got a stomach stapled or
something they showing off their new
ribcage or something it's all good
getting all right let's take another
call here here we go hey man just wanted
to share with you some different stuff
that's been getting to me lately when I
was a trip to Europe with my girlfriend
at the time then for a little over a
year I plan on going to like five or six
countries adventuring for like a month
and a few days okay see where my trip to
Europe with the girlfriend man I can
relate to that I went on a trip to
Europe with my girlfriend back in the
day and we had a pretty decent time I
think I don't know maybe we did homeward
and just a couple days in I found out
that she cheated on me back home so I
freaked out of course I broke up with
her and there was just it was a
nightmare of a situation I call I get so
intense but I'm really just having a
trouble with with getting over it
getting over her and I was wondering if
you could give me any advice love you
dude
love you too man thanks for calling I'm
sorry you dealing with that you know I'm
sorry at all that that happened to you
yeah it can really have really hurt your
feelings when people do that to us man
and I mean I only know that a lot of
times I've done that to women and I've
seen how much it hurts them and
you know she if she really does care
about you she really did or she really
does or she really did then she probably
was really hurting too
so many times when somebody does us
wrong we think oh man [ __ ] them and but
also you know what also sucks is doing
somebody wrong and having to live with
that wrong
painful man
did having to talk to your girlfriend
and your boyfriend and knowing you've
been lying to them and there's there's a
pet that's a it's like having a dirty
treasure chest in the ocean bro
it's like having a treasure chest that
has no treasure in it at all and it's
just really just a [ __ ] shoebox so
she probably it was probably wasn't fun
for as much as it was painful for you
I'm just saying there's a way to heal it
up I think if you think like hey I'm
sorry that you I bet it was painful for
you to live with that and I bet it was
painful that you did that and had to
live with that and I'm sorry that that
happened to you I'm sorry you even
though she did it to you because then
you take control you get some control
then then you're not a victim anymore
you're not a victim of what she did
you're a your offering you were saying
hey I can really I can understand what
it's like to do something wrong and how
miserable it feels or how tough it feels
to live with that pain alright that
uncomfort that discomfort that decomp so
you can let her know that and sometimes
man it's crazy sometimes I've been in
relationships where somebody did me
wrong and then I stayed with them just
so I could hold it against him
that man
man I remember staying with this one
girls worked for a while and I just
would think sometimes man I can't stand
this girl but I must stay with her just
because
it's almost like out of spite I stayed
with her just like well sorry man
it's almost like I stayed you know I
stayed with a girl once because uh you
know I didn't like her
I just because by by staying with her it
gave me something like weird control or
something by staying with someone who
had done me wrong it let me be the
victim and if I could be the victim at
all it always gave me this place to
operate from
and in in hindsight it was such a [ __ ]
move man I'm not saying that's you I'm
just I'm saying for myself and I think
back on myself it it brings me some you
know a little bit of shame because I did
that
you know I find for myself sometimes I
stay with certain things because it
gives me an excuse
I wanna stay with this person that
cheated on me because as long as I can
always remind them they cheated on me
then that gives me a leg to stand on
that makes me a little better than them
or I'm gonna keep drinking or I'm gonna
keep smoking cigarettes because as long
as I as long as that's my problem
and as long as I keep going in circles
of trying to quit smoking or not smoking
or whatever as long as I keep that
little problem going I'll never have to
deal with whatever my real problem is
as long as I keep this little
fish in the bowl I'll never even have to
really see what the shark is
so I just keep bout yeah I'm trying to
quit I quit for a few days I'm back I
quit I'm back
and sometimes it's like I don't know if
I even really want to quit
because if I quit that if I quit if I
quit smoking the numbers gonna have to
phone then it's gonna be well whatever
what an exit I'm gonna to look at what's
really going on with me
you know much to [ __ ] be Neil
Armstrong and myself man not Lance
Bruyneel ain't talkin about that [ __ ]
nut boy with us or at the cycle
I'm talkin about that [ __ ] Spacey
daddy
but you said now about getting over a
man I think the truth is dude I think
you are over her
I think you just keep it around because
you don't want to keep you don't want to
move forward
and that's just a gas bro and that's
kind of messed up with me to say that
and I'm just guessing like by your tone
and stuff but also man I'm just saying
that cuz I can relate
in a stop
I know girls all the time for this and
that and and the truth was I didn't
really even probably care about them
anymore
I was just afraid to man up and [ __ ]
live my life I was too lazy or too
stagnant or to something to [ __ ] just
say hey that's that let's go you know
what created this fake breeze that was
just pushing against me then but I was
operating the wind machine secretly on
the side and I don't have the you know
it's like aw man I can barely make it
through this through this win but but as
long as I every now and then reach over
and crank up the [ __ ]
crank up the wind machine the fan then
the wind will just keep coming I'm
making my own damn [ __ ]
so anyway man I wish you look and really
what I really wish you man is the same
thing that I wish myself sometimes
confidence
confidence to say hey you know what
enough enough of that and let's get
going huh thank you for calling man
thank you for everybody calling we can
do this we can do this other people have
done this this life we got this let's go
get this bruh is Sadie Hawkins man these
[ __ ] lookin for us
with that nice shirt you know what I'm
sayin I ain't talkin about [ __ ] uh
ain't talking about tiff with them with
them three-point [ __ ] kneecaps daddy
with them dunkaroos right there I'm
talking about getting that nice shirt
from a real lady I'm talking about
expecting good things to happen to
myself instead of immediately looking at
the bad ones every day because that's
what's comfortable
man I wonder someone's how far I could
go if I really gave myself a chance
you know I really do thank you guys for
being here for with me today
and for me today I don't know sometimes
know what this podcast is about but
but sometimes you know some of oddly man
it's like exactly what I need sometimes
so and I know wherever I am right now
this is where I need to be sometimes
it's not always comfortable but this is
where I need to be and sometimes you
know all we get to be with the people
you want to be with or the be in the the
house you want to be him right now or
the get to have the job you want right
now but but those things are the the the
those things are coming they're they're
gonna come to us when we're ready so I'm
right where I need to be today you guys
be good to yourselves man you deserve it
huh get that hitter right here at Bishop
gun man these boys are good
you
we're making it home in town a hundred
days your mama bleep for my Restless
soon as Travis McCready that lead singer
and that ain't made of dollar high spin
but where it's going ain't you me yet
I still get wet I'm bound let go you got
this baby
bacon wrong
[Music]
taking their time you're making good
time
making good time
[Music]
most all of my plans slip right through
my hands and windup next to me broken on
if they'll spiral wasn't our glance I'm
feeling I'm about an hour
I'll shut it down
but how
I feel right shoutout
[Music]
making good time yeah girl make a good
time
[Music]
making good time baby
making good time
[Applause]
right what you need to be brother
[Music]
but I'm importing good scream for the
shave
pretty good shape for the shape
[Music]
boy pick bandit burn
let us all fit me today I hate seed
holdman powerful to date almost here
mama recipes
[Music]
take that bigjon how about that fade-out
huh ice John frozen John whatever that
guy's name was how about that fade out
right there Big Daddy you guys be good
man be good to yourself huh guy